[Music]
it was a March for change build as a Do
or Die moment
led by a former cricketer and prime
minister vying for a political comeback
everyone here to get as close as they
can to Imran Khan that is until this
panic
on top of the container Mr Khan is
carried away
we're downstairs we'd left the roof
minutes before
there's worry the attacker may be on
board
[Music]
and just behind us is Imran Khan he's
also trying to make an escape clearly
dazed and wounded
but moments later surrounded by a sea of
supporters he finds the strength to
reassure them
[Applause]
but it's a deeply anxious aftermath
everyone unsettled
hours later Punjab police released this
video claiming it shows the gunman being
wrestled to the ground
[Music]
Khan was ousted in a no-confidence vote
this year he's been pushing for an early
election and I spoke to him just before
he made his way upstairs
the government are concerned about
violence they've talked about credible
terrorist threats are you worried about
that
the only terrorist threat for us is the
government
and the handlers
does it worry the prospect of
well I'm
I'm confident that and I've been on the
road for six months now
what I've seen I'm confident that I will
be able to direct it through elections
the government has no choice but to hold
elections sooner or later and I think
it's only a matter of time
for now he is simply out of danger his
team says it was a clear assassination
attempt he had momentum and this may
well generate much more Cordelia Lynch
Sky News was there about Pakistan